elon musk is the world's richest band
he's also probably the best entrepreneur
of all time but elon musk just made 23
billion dollars in a single day this is
a wild story so pay attention obviously
elon is the ceo of tesla it's the
leading electric vehicle company in the
world it's worth over trillion dollars
and yesterday they reported their
earnings now they blew wall street
expectations out of the water they
reported 18.8 billion dollars and their
adjusted earnings per share was at 3 and
22 cents they also reported about 5
billion dollars in adjusted ebitda and
about three billion dollars in gaap
income this is a monster of a company
now how the hell did elon make 23
billion dollars in one day well he's got
a very unique compensation plan that's
all predicated on the company doing well
both from a stock price and financial
performance now as a reminder elon's
compensation he gets zero dollars as a
salary and his pay package requires that
tesla's market cap and financial growth
hits a series of escalating targets the
better they do the more elon gets paid
and so when tesla reported that 18
billion dollars and they went ahead and
they reported five billion dollars of
ebitda combined with the previous
three-quarters results that surpassed
some recent milestones that trigger
vesting of the 9th 10th and 11th of 12
tranches of options that were granted to
musk in his 2018 pay package basically
elon musk bet on himself back in 2018
and now he's getting a bag because of it
if we look at exactly how these options
work tesla went ahead and said look you
get 8.4 million tesla shares at 70 and
one cent each it's about a 90 discount
to wednesday's closing price and
according to the current stock price
those three option transfers those will
give elon about 23 billion dollars or
about 7.7 billion per tranche in profit
after he goes and executes it now of
course he can't simply just take the
stock and immediately dump it there's
some rules around this he's gotta hold
the stock for at least five years and
the board's gotta sign off on all of
this but elon musk the world's richest
man just made 23 billion dollars in a
single day because of a 2018 pay package
where he bet on himself now if we take a
look at the tesla stock price we can see
that it has just been up and to the
right since january 1st of 2020 the
stock continues to do well elon
continues to get paid more and more
money then if we take a look at what
elon's been saying well he's more
bullish now than he's ever been the
exact quote is that the future is very
exciting i've never been more optimistic
or excited about the future of tesla
than i am right now and then of course
if we start to think about why this may
be happening tesla's the leader in
electric vehicles but they're actually
benefiting from the more advertising
that their competitors do the better
tesla does what do i mean well during
the super bowl gm bmw nissan kia and
polestar they all had electric vehicle
ads in the super bowl and tesla had none
actually tesla has zero dollars for
their marketing budget but as you can
see there tesla's sales absolutely
exploded because their competitors were
running ads everyone knows tesla's the
best electric vehicle company in the
world and so if their competitors
convince people to buy electric vehicles
they're just funneling their customers
to go to tesla if that continues to
happen tesla will continue to do well
and if tesla continues to do well elon
musk will continue to get paid over and
over and over again 23 billion dollars
in a single day is insane but he's been
working on this stuff for decades and we
need as many builders and problem
solvers in our society as possible kudos
to elon i hope they pay him even more
money because what he's doing is quite
impressive hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time